so what I tried to do with the book is I
wanted to blend sort of some of the
stories and things that have happened in
this room that I think have been so
culturally relevant with things that you
guys don't know about me so I talk about
personal stories and and family stuff
and things that I haven't opened up that
much about some in some cases that I
haven't opened up about at all before
and I sort of blend that to sort of how
I sort of came to be here right now and
how that relates to everything else
politically so I thought maybe four I'll
tell you a couple things today but I
thought maybe the best way to do it for
today is kind of just go back to the to
the beginning just sort of career-wise
because it has been quite an adventure
and you know it's funny when you when
you lock yourself in a room for a couple
of days a week a couple hours a day
really trying to do something that
that's valuable and it it can really
make you just sort of rethink rethink
everything and I think rethink not not
just rethink everything I think it can
really help you solidify a lot of the
things that you think so I think one of
the things that I've really learned in
the last six months or so as I've been
writing this and especially in the last
couple months as it really was was
getting whittled down into something
especially towards towards the end what
I really wanted to say something say
something new and different is that it
makes you challenge all the things that
you think and when I had to do certain
research on certain fact-based things
and you know see potentially what my
blind spots are and things like that but
then also go into my family history and
be very very appreciative of of where I
came from and really we went way back
into my family history because we were
trying to find out what my American
story is and actually as I'm telling you
this right now
today is July 30th 2019 my dad is not
watching this right now I don't think
because he is at his retirement party my
dad turned seventy two months ago and
he's retiring after you know the forty
five year career he's worked at the same
sales company in in midtown Manhattan
for the last 34 years I think it's 34
years he just celebrated this year and
he's retiring next week so it seems sort
of fitting to me as I'm writing this
sort of family story and all of this
that my dad maybe he's watching this
maybe you guys are watching right now
dad how are you if you're watching he at
the at the retirement party but it seems
sort of fitting like my dad's retiring
right now and I'm writing this story
about about that's about my family but
I'm not writing it to be an
autobiography and the book is not an
autobiography although there are
personal stories it's more to frame like
what my story is that brings me here
that is so exactly the same as most of
your stories are so we were trying to
break it down and it's like on my on my
dad's side my great-great grandparents
were were first-generation immigrants
from Belarus and my great-grandfather
died while my grandfather was like six
months old and they were he had I think
five brothers and sisters and they were
living it's I mean it's the same old
story that everybody hears they were
living in the Lower East Side which is
where all the immigrants especially from
Eastern Europe that came through Ellis
Island that they all lived and it was
like you know basically one bedroom with
five or six kids and then my widowed
great-grandmother and my grandfather who
had they grew up with just absolutely
nothing and then he worked I remember my
grandfather grandpa already on my dad's
side in second he died when I was in
second grade but I remember being around
first grade or something and he was a
great golfer and I have a couple of his
hole-in-one statues and they in the
green room over there and I remember he
was teaching me how to golf and I
remember him once telling me he bought
me a golf club like a little kids golf
club and I remember him once telling me
that his first job was for 25 cents an
hour so he grew up in abject poverty
with parents that were you know from
from another country first-generation
immigrants and was was lower class then
he worked really hard became a
lithographer my grandma Minnie who he
eventually married was the first person
in my family to go to college on either
side and then she
ended up being a typing teacher in
Brooklyn but they became sort of they
were sort of lower middle class to
middle class then my parents moved on
from that and became middle-class to -
upper middle class I'm doing okay now
like it's the great American story that
it doesn't matter whether you're Italian
or Jewish or Irish or Latino or black or
white or whatever it is it's like we all
have these stories in our families and I
wanted to sort of illustrate that
because I think one of the things that
we're fighting right now is there is a
feeling out there that somehow this this
experiment of America is somehow wrong
or or or is a bust or we should feel
guilty about it or something like that
and and I like calling it an experiment
which is a phrase that I got from Dennis
Prager actually who I've interviewed
here many times and I've done a couple
videos for Prager you because all
America is really is an experiment like
we're testing this thing out can people
live with with maximum freedoms can we
have a country that welcomes people that
that they can bring all of their talents
and skills and traditions and ethnic
backgrounds and cultural backgrounds and
fit into the tapestry of America while
still respecting our freedoms we've done
it here that melting pot better than any
country in the history of the world and
I think we don't step back to be
appreciative of that so as I was writing
this and learning more I mean this was
truly a learning process I did
ancestry.com which is one of the
sponsors by the way of our of our
podcast I think you go to ancestry.com
slash Rubin i but i did it in the midst
of all this because I wanted to find out
more about my family tree to find out
more about what my answers to ancestors
went through so that I could be a guy
that sits in his garage talking to a
camera about freedom I mean that's
pretty [ __ ] spectacular it's it's
it's incredible it's unimaginable I
don't think any of my grandparents on
either side could could possibly imagine
that this is real it's it's just it's
just incredible